>> HE WASN'T IN A GANG.
HE DIDN'T DO DRUGS.
THAT WAS MY ONLY NEPHEW.
HE WAS 15 YEARS OLD.
TWO YEARS, $10,000, NOTHING.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> I'M SO SORRY.
>> THAT'S FROM OUR TOWN HALL
LAST YEAR, THE WOMAN I SHARED
THAT HUG WITH WAS MICHELLE.
HER NEPHEW WAS MURDERED BY A
VICIOUS GANG.
AT THAT TIME, NO ARRESTS WERE
MADE AFTER TWO YEARS OF
INVESTIGATION, AND ONE YEAR
LATER, HAVE HIS KILLERS BEEN
BROUGHT TO JUSTICE?
JOINING ME NOW IS ROCHELLE AND
POLY.
IT'S HIS MOTHER.
ROCHELLE, IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU
AGAIN.
I DID MEET YOU LAST TIME.
YOU COULDN'T BE WITH US.
>> THAT WAS DIFFICULT.
I KNOW.
POLLY, TELL US.
YOU HAVE NO LEADS IN THIS
INVESTIGATION?
>> NO LEADS.
WE NEED AS MUCH HELP AS WE CAN
TO BRING THE KILLERS TO JUSTICE.
THAT'S WHY THEY'RE TRYING FOR US
TO KEEP THE STORY HERE SO WE CAN
GET HELP.
ALL KIDS' LIVES MATTER TO ME.
AND MY SON WAS TAKEN FROM ME,
AND NO MOTHER SHOULD HAVE TO
DEAL WITH THAT.
SO IT'S KIND OF HARD FOR ME
RIGHT NOW.
>> POLLY, NO WORDS.
ROCHELLE, ONE IN SIX MURDERS ARE
SOLVED IN THIS CITY.
ONE IN SIX.
IT'S THE LOWEST SOLVING MURDERS
RATE IN THE COUNTRY.
THE WORST CALLED CLEARANCE RATE
IN THE COUNTRY.
HOW DOES THAT MAKE EVERYBODY
HERE FEEL?
>> IT MAKES ME FEEL HORRIBLE.
IT MAKES ME FEEL THAT WE AS
PEOPLE DON'T VALUE LIFE, DON'T
VALUE CHILDREN.
BECAUSE WE DON'T VALUE ANY
VALUES ANYMORE.
DEMETRIUS, THE LOVING SWEET KID.
HE WAS 96 POUNDS, HE WAS 4'9".
THEY BURNT HIM BEYOND
RECOGNITION.
I HAED TO GET DENTAL RECORDS TO
IDENTIFY HIM.
WE WERE -- WE HAD TO NO SERVICE,
NO WAY TO SAY GOOD-BYE.
WE HAD TO TAKE HIM STRAIGHT FROM
THE MORGUE TO THE GRAVE.
WE HAD TO HAVE A MEMORIAL
SERVICE.
WHAT WE KEEP DOING AND THERE'S
BEEN THREE YEARS.
THERE HASN'T BEEN ANY --
NOTHING.
NOBODY SAID ANYTHING.
NOBODY HAS TALKING ABOUT
ANYTHING.
NOBODY -- NOTHING.
WE NEED TO STOP WAITING UNTIL IT
HITS OUR DOORSTEP.
WE NEED TO SAY SOMETHING IF WE
SEE SOMETHING.
>> EVERYONE.
THE NO SNITCH THING, IF IT'S
WRONG, REPORT IT.
POLLY, YOU SEE COVERAGE OF
CRIMES AROUND THE UNITED STATES,
THEY'RE SERIOUS.
MASS SHOOTINGS.
DO YOU FEEL THEY GET THE
COVERAGE IN CITIES LIKE US, ST.
LOUIS, DETROIT, OAKLAND.
DOES IT GET THE COVERAGE?
IS IT ACCEPTABLE TO ANYONE?
>> NO, IT'S NOT ACCEPTABLE TO
ANYONE.
NO I DON'T THINK YOU HAVE TO
HAVE COVERAGE OF IT.
WE NEED TO STICK TOGETHER, WE
NEED TO SPEAK OUT.
VIOLENCE IS THE WORST THING
EVER.
THESE ARE OUR KIDS.
THEY ARE IMPORTANT TO US.
>> Laura: THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE.
YOU ALMOST DIDN'T COME.
WE REALLY, REALLY APPRECIATE IT.
I NEVER FORGOT DEMETRIUS, NOT
ONE DAY SINCE LAST YEAR.
IT'S A $15,000 REWARD?
>> YEAH.
>> Laura: IT'S $20,000 NOW.
>> THANK YOU.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> Laura: $20,000, SOMEONE CAN
TELL US ABOUT THIS MURDER.
WE HAVE SOME TIME FOR SOME
QUESTIONS FROM THE AUDIENCE,
SOME POINTS.
I THINK WE CAN GO TO MARLENE
FIRST.
MARLENE?
>> HI, I'M MARLENE, HI,
EVERYONE.
I FEEL YOUR PAIN.
I LOST A BROTHER TO GUN
VIOLENCE.
AND IT WAS THE MOST HEART
WRENCHING THING TO EVER GO
THROUGH, OH, MY GOSH, IT WAS.
BUT, FOR ME, IT'S -- IT'S NOT A
QUESTIONABLE STATEMENT, IT'S
LIKE WE NEED THE FOUNDATION OF
LOVE AND UNITY AND PEACE.
WE NEED TO GET ALONG WITH EACH
OTHER.
THAT'S WHAT IT IS.
WE NEED TO GET ALONG.
GETTING ALONG IS BACK IN THE DAY
WE HAD THE BIG MAMA, WE HAD
PEOPLE LOOKING OUT FOR EACH
OTHER.
THAT'S WHAT MEANS THE MOST TO
ME.
MY BROTHER WAS LOVING AND KIND,
HE WENT TO SCHOOL, WENT TO
COLLEGE, WASN'T IN A GANG.
HE GOT CAUGHT IN A CROSS FIRE
AND DIED INSTANTLY.
SHOT IN THE HEAD.
WE FOUND ONE KILLER.
WE DID.
WHAT MAKES US GROUNDED AND KEEPS
US EXCITED, WE HOLD THE LEGACY.
AND OUR LEGACY IS TO LOVE ONE
ANOTHER, HAVE PEACE AND UNITY
AND STOP HATING AND ALWAYS TELL
PEOPLE, THE REASON WE DON'T LIKE
EACH OTHER OR BECAUSE WE DON'T
GET ALONG --
>> Laura: WE HAVE TO CARE ABOUT
EACH OTHER AS FELLOW AMERICANS.
I WANT TO GO BACK TO THE PANEL
AND THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THAT.
YOU HEARD THE STORIES.
TWO WOMEN, TWO TRAGIC STORIES.
LET'S GO TO YOU.
LACK OF -- A LACK OF LOVE,
UNITY, ROLE MODELS, ENOUGH
SUPPORT FOR THE POLICE, ENOUGH
POLICE.
IT'S A LOT.
WE DIDN'T TOUCH ON DRUGS IN THIS
SITUATION.
BUT DRUGS HAVE BEEN A PART OF A
LOT OF THE VIOLENCE, SELLING
THEM, PUSHING THEM, BEING ON
THEM, GETTING ON THEM BECAUSE OF
THIS SITUATION.
HOW IMPORTANT IS THAT?
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT, I BELIEVE
SOME OF THE MOTHERS HERE,
POLLY -- MY HEART GOES OUT.
>> THANK YOU.
I'VE SEEN IT WHEN YOU HAVE
CHILDREN COME HOME WITH $400
SNEAKERS ON, THEY BEEN OUT ALL
NIGHT LONG, GO TO SCHOOL, THEY
BECOME THE HEAD OF HOUSE HOLD.
A DRUG KID WILL TELL YOU,
LISTEN, WHY SHOULD I GO TO
SCHOOL WHEN I CAN MAKE $200 OR
$300 A DAY AND COME HOME?
THE FOUNDATION STARTS AT THE
HOME.
DRUGS IS DEFINITELY THE SCOURGE
OF ANY COMMUNITY.
BUT IT BECAME AN EPIDEMIC WHEN
IT STARTED TO GO TO OTHER
COMMUNITIES.
IT'S ALWAYS BEEN HERE IN THE
BLACK COMMUNITY.
>> Laura: JOSEPH, ON THIS ISSUE,
WE HAVE A LOT OF PAIN, OPIOIDS,
METH.
NOW WE'RE GOING TO LEGALIZE
DRUGS.
IT'S GOING TO SOLVE OUR PROBLEM,
KNOCK OUT THE VIOLENCE.
YOU'RE SEEING A LOT OF VIOLENCE
IN COMMUNITIES WHERE IT'S
LEGALIZED.
YOU BRING IN CHEAPER, MORE
POWERFUL STUFF TO UNDERCUT THE
LEGAL SALES.
>> FOR LACK OF CENSORSHIP, I
WON'T SAY WHAT'S IN MY MIND.
I'LL SAY IT'S NOT JUST OPIOID.
IN ONE, IT'S AN EPIDEMIC.
THE OTHER IT'S A SCOURGE.
IN OUR COMMUNITY, THE SECOND AND
THIRD GENERATION OF CRACK
BABIES.
WE'RE SEEING A LARGE INFLUX IN
THE NUMBER OF KIDS THAT HAVE
LEARNING DISABILITIES.
WE DON'T TALK ABOUT THAT IN
TERMS OF HOW PEOPLE GET
ATTRACTED TO WHAT BRINGS THEM TO
THE GANG.
A LOT OF THEM ARE LOOKING FOR
SOMEONE TO LOVE THEM, SOMEONE TO
HELP THEM.
SOMEONE TO ACCEPT THEM.
THAT'S WHAT YOU FIND HAPPENING
IN A LOT OF THESE COMMUNITIES,
PARTICULARLY OURS.
THERE'S HOPE IN THIS ROOM.
PEOPLE CAME HERE TO SHARE THEIR
PAPE AND DEMAND ACTION FROM
WITHIN OURSELVES AND FROM OUR
LEADERSHIP.
>> I WANT PEOPLE TO KNOW WE HAVE
PUT VIOLENCE ON TRIAL IN
ILLINOIS.
VIOLENCE IS ON TRIAL IN
AND WE ARE TURNING PAIN INTO
POLICY.
PAIN INTO POLICY.
I'
I AM A GRIEVING FATHER.
IT DOESN'T FEEL GOOD WHEN YOU
LOSE YOUR CHILD.
I NEED EVERYBODY IN AMERICA TO
BE PATRIOTIC.
HELP US PASS COMPREHENSIVE
LEGISLATION ON VIOLENCE AND
HUMAN HEALTH CRISIS, IT'S A
DISEASE.
WE WILL ALL BE ELIMINATED FROM
THIS PLANET IF WE DO NOT GET
CONTROL.
LEGISLATION IS VERY KEY RIGHT